hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president biden strongly defending his
decision to pull u.s troops out of
afghanistan
amid pressure from critics citing
taliban gains
and fears that without american military
support the afghan government could
collapse
house minority whip steve scalise shares
his thoughts on the administration's
strategy
and weighs in on former president
trump's latest battle
with big tech virgin galactic founder
sir
richard branson will join five others on
a test flight to the edge of space
sunday if he succeeds he'd achieve the
feat nine days ahead of amazon rival
jeff bezos former nasa astronaut and
engineering professor at columbia
university mike massimino
discusses the two commercial spacecrafts
set to take off this month
and what it means for the future of
space travel
plus commentary from fox news
contributor mark thiessen
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast
where we take a deeper look at the
stories important to you
you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
i'm lauren simonetti i'm charles payne
i'm tammy bruce and this
is the fox news rundown
friday july 9th 2021 i'm lisa brady
the end is near in afghanistan but an
accelerated u.s withdrawal is raising
concern
about holding on to hard-fought gains
you should try to do it in a way that
you can leave the country stabilized as
much as possible
and and i would like to see that planned
by president biden i've yet to we speak
with house minority whip steve scalise
about that
and more i'm chris foster the
billionaire richard branson goes into
space sunday with jeff bezos right
behind him in a week and a half
we're seeing a significant step now in
having these private companies
take a larger role and hopefully they'll
be successful and they'll be
economic growth and we'll have a
thriving commercial space program just
like we have a
driving commercial airliner and i'm mark
thiessen i've got the final word on the
fox news rundown
[Music]
president biden is defending the end in
afghanistan announcing thursday that the
u.s military mission will be over
as of august 31st he says staying longer
would only be a recipe for remaining
indefinitely nearly 20 years of
experience has shown us
that the current security situation only
confirms
that just one more year of fighting in
afghanistan is not a solution
he says the afghan people and their
politicians must decide the future and
while there's concern about recent
taliban moves
seizing territory and border crossings a
trillion dollars has been spent to train
and equip
afghan forces some of the u.s forces
serving now
have parents who also fought in
afghanistan 20 years ago
i will not send another generation of
americans to war in afghanistan
with no reasonable expectation of
achieving a different outcome the
president says the u.s achieved its
goals in afghanistan which included
justice for the 9 11 attacks
not nation building but answering a
reporter's question
he also says it's not a mission
accomplished moment
calling to mind a declaration made about
iraq by president george w
bush who ended up surging more troops in
and the obama biden administration would
later face criticism
for pulling out of iraq where terrorist
groups including isis
then flourished now president biden says
the us
is repositioning counter terrorism
resources and adapting its posture
to meet the threats where they are well
obviously
you get concerned when you see the
telegraphing
to the enemy that we're going to be
pulling out louisiana republican
congressman steve scalise
is the house minority whip and
ultimately you
you know you want to make sure that that
an unstable region doesn't get more
unstable and
the afghan government uh you know
there's there's a lot of people that
want to make sure that they're able to
to not let this get taken over by
terrorist organizations and you know
that's going to be a threat that we're
going to have to continue to watch
what about that argument that it could
leave a vacuum and fuel insurgency
um similar to what happened when we left
iraq i mean
the president's take on it is look
another year of being in afghanistan the
u.s troops being there
isn't going to make a difference at this
point there just isn't a military
solution
well now that we are there but planning
to ultimately pull out you should try to
do it in a way that
you can leave the country stabilized as
much as possible
and and i would like to see that planned
uh by president biden i've yet to
but that should be a main concern that
we don't lose the gains we made
and that we don't allow this to become
another terrorist haven they've also
been rocket attacks on u.s locations
in iraq after recent u.s strikes on
militants backed by iran
what else do you think this president
could or
should be doing in the region
one thing president biden needs to do is
stand up to the bullies around the world
uh you see this with iran i mean frankly
president biden spent more of his time
trying to renegotiate how to help iran
get a nuclear weapon
the bad iran deal that president trump
had gotten us out of
uh president biden's trying to get back
in it and of course he was there
with president obama when they
originally negotiated that bad deal it
was bad for america and bad for israel
and so uh stand up to russia stand up to
china
stand up to iran and we've yet to see
that kind of toughness from president
biden
look our enemies around the world test
any new president uh it doesn't matter
how long ends at some point every
president gets tested
and i think we're starting to see some
of those tests now on president biden
and frankly so far he's failed
those tests he's got to get tougher
against the bad
actors around the world former president
trump is now suing
tech giants including google facebook
and twitter
arguing he has been unfairly censored
after the capital riot
given that first amendment protections
by and large don't apply
for private companies though how much of
a case do you think he has
well obviously it's been tough taking on
big tech but more i think you're seeing
more and more
organized efforts to do that and look in
congress there are republicans and
democrats
that have frustrations with big tech for
different reasons
and you saw recently we put together a
task force to hold big tech accountable
and to put transparency
in place that doesn't exist you know if
you're a consumer
you're whatever your smart device is
it's tracking so many elements of your
daily activities
and in many cases you can't find out
what it's tracking it's selling your
data
the aggregating and selling of personal
information
is getting worse and so standing up for
privacy rights is really important
but ultimately standing up against big
tech censorship
this canceled culture that's alive and
well in silicon valley it's got to end
and and look you're going to see a lot
of different attempts
to confront this and reign it in
is there growing support in congress to
do more than hold
hearings though yes i think you're
starting to see legislation come
together
some that's bipartisan you're also
seeing uh whether it's
those of us on the republican side that
want to put some accountability in place
and
you know whether it's addressing section
230 uh whether it's
just looking at these entities that get
too big
and you you saw this with apt getting
broken up
it's it's not that companies that that
are monopolies
you know once they start acting like a
monopoly shutting other competitors out
and shutting down free speech that's
when you start seeing the tide turn and
i think right now there is a tide
turning against the real abuses within
big tech
and and they can clean it up internally
they need to clean up their act
but if not you're going to see
congressional action and they're pushing
congress
more and more to come together to
address some of these problems
if you were on the threshold of actually
having a vote in congress
on something like section 230 on reining
in the liability protections for these
companies
do you think that would be enough to
spur internal action
at these tech giants or
would you anticipate having to actually
pass something
and then maybe fight it out in court if
they you know filed a lawsuit or
something over it
you would like to think that that these
big tech companies
seeing that their abuses are being
called out would be enough unfortunately
some are you know or very arrogant
against even their own customers
and and look i'm a free market guy i
would love to see competitors
really rise up uh to be able to to come
and fill the void
you know if in any monopoly if you start
acting arrogant in a way where you just
stop paying attention to the very people
who are your customers
it always catches up to whatever company
it is and you know history going back
over 100 years
has shown that ultimately if you're
abusing your
monopoly you're abusing and not paying
attention to your customers your
customers will ultimately rise up
and go find somebody else and uh and so
i think you see on both fronts
whether it's congressional action or the
likelihood of competitors coming up to
to ultimately rival some of these big
big
tech giants that are acting more and
more like monopolies who don't care
about the very customers they serve
democrats in congress and some
republicans too have been
very critical of the former president
though do you
think that his continued involvement
on this issue hurts the chances for
bipartisanship when it comes to
cracking down on big tech companies no i
think the more people that are standing
up to big tech the better
and that's going to that's going to help
address the problem again whether they
fix their own problems internally or
or sticks through market forces or
through legislation
the more people you have raising
attention to this the better i mean look
president trump
uh was uh you know was probably one of
the most popular people on social media
and and then so many of these platforms
kicked him off
you can't find a consistent policy it
seems like they just kick off somebody
they don't like you've got the ayatollah
out there
you know spreading a death to america
message and that seems to be okay
you see other messages that promote
violence that's okay
if a year ago we would have just posted
on certain social media platforms that
the
the covet 19 virus may have started in
the lab in wuhan china
it was banned by many social media sites
well today
almost every medical expert who's
objectively looked at this said it
probably did start
in that wuhan lab so big tech has been
wrong on the way that they censor people
uh
you know whether it's the hunter biden
story uh during the campaign
right before the election where the the
washington post
story was censored that turned out to be
accurate
and and i think more and more you're
starting to see uh
these actions by these these big tech
oligarchs
and then i think the public's starting
to to rise up against it
one heated debate around the country
right now continues to be
about voting laws uh in texas
democrats are saying their recent
walkout that blocked a vote on changes
uh paid off because some controversial
provisions were
stripped out at least for now is this
becoming a losing argument politically
for republicans either in texas or
around the country
actually it's a losing argument for
democrats the fact that they
are standing up against voter integrity
laws
you know showing picture id it's
something every american
understands i mean if you go fly on a
plane today before you get on that
airplane you've got to show picture id
if you went to a major league baseball
game and tried to get in
with a will call ticket they're going to
make your show id to get that will call
ticket
yet they say it's it's racist to require
an id
to vote i think people get that i've
seen national polling on this most
americans
black white republican democrat support
picture id
you know the idea of one person one vote
is sacrosanct i'd fight for the right
for everybody who's legally able to vote
to vote one time i think people are
tired of the double standard and they're
tired of the hypocrisy
from the left where they're criticizing
something that they themselves
don't even have a problem with their
home states i have one
other question for you and it's it's one
of the trillion dollar
questions persisting
whether an infrastructure package can
actually pass with bipartisan
support are republican votes there
in the house yes there is an ability to
get a bipartisan infrastructure bill and
i've seen the lead republican on the
house transportation committee sam
graves put together
a really good package uh probably in the
a billion dollar range which is still a
lot of money
fully paid for that not only does roads
and bridges and ports and waterways
improvements
uh as well as broadband but it also does
reforms to the permitting process
i think one of the biggest problems with
road projects in any state is that you
have all these duplicated laws people
abuse the court system to drag projects
out
and so a road project or you know you're
trying to upgrade a bridge it might
take you 10 years to do a project that
should only take two
because the permitting process is so
broken and so we reform that as well i
think all that
is bipartisan with american voters
whether we're able to get that agreement
in washington but speaker pelosi
has to drop this ridiculous idea that uh
home health care workers being unionized
is somehow now called infrastructure
or the green new deal where you're
telling people which kind of car they
can and can't drive
and then you know most 97 percent of
drivers who drive fossil fuel cars
are gonna pay for three percent of
drivers who drive uh
electric vehicles to buy charging
stations that are funded by taxpayer
dollars
uh those are the kind of things that
we've got to drop out
and and get back to traditional
infrastructure and then you could have a
bipartisan deal
house minority whip steve scalise thanks
so much for your time
it's great to be with you lisa
[Music]
this is mark thiessen with your fox news
commentary coming up
calling it a dream come true on sunday
the british billionaire businessman
richard branson and a crew of five will
take off on a short flight to space
he'll be beating amazon founder jeff
bezos by nine days but says it's not a
competition
also that he knows no one believes him
when he says that branson's company is
virgin galactic
bezos owns blue origin he's planning to
go to space a week from next tuesday
july 20th
joined by his brother an auction winner
and wally funk
she was one of the so-called mercury 13
a group of women who went through and
passed a private astronaut training
program in the early 60s
at 82 she'll be the oldest person ever
in space breaking john glenn's record
it's a little bit different the way that
each one of these companies are going to
be doing it
richard branson the virgin galactic
spacecraft
has a mother ship more or less that
takes off from a runway with the
spaceship attached
mike masamino went to space twice as an
astronaut on nasa's shuttle missions to
service the hubble space telescope
he's now an engineering professor at
columbia university and the senior
advisor for space programs at the
intrepid sea air and space museum in new
york
and then the spaceship gets dropped and
then we'll light its
engine to uh to make it uh into space
a little over 50 miles above our planet
and then come back to land on a runway
and uh
jeff bezos uh who is a real fan of the
space program since he was a kid
named his spaceship new shepard the new
shepherd rocket ship
more or less mimics what alan shepard
did which was a suborbital flight kind
of going up and down and getting about
15 minutes of a space flight in that way
like alex sheppard did
and uh that's what that's what jeff
bezos will be experiencing so a little
bit different he'll be
doing it more traditionally launching
into space we'll get a little bit higher
than richard branson will
and then he'll land close to where he uh
he launched from
and that will be his experience for now
they're not really
i wouldn't call them trips yet they're
not going anywhere there's no
destination they're kind of more like
rides i mean are they gonna they'll get
some weightlessness do they see the
curvature of the earth
yeah i guess it is kind of like i mean
it's there's all different
ways to experience space the way i did
it was on the space shuttle and
astronauts from around the world that
are on the space station they're on the
space station for long periods of time
this is a little bit different this is
more of an experience
the passengers the astronauts are going
to get a chance
to experience a launch which is always
exciting
no matter where you're going that's the
commonality between all these things
is leaving the planet and then what
they'll be doing is experience a few
minutes of weightlessness
a chance to unstrap from their seats
look out the window
then observe the the earth the beauty of
the planet they'll be high enough where
they can see the curve of the planet
not the whole planet is in its entirety
they won't be high enough to see that
but they'll get a chance to see what the
atmosphere looks like from up there and
the blackness of
space uh against it which is uh
which is a pretty cool thing to look
look at and they'll get a few minutes of
weightlessness as well so float around a
little bit
and then they'll they'll come back any
training for this kind of thing to be
crass about it how many of these people
are gonna throw up
uh i don't know i i think uh i mean i
i threw up on my first space flight but
again it was a different experience we
were there for
for quite a bit longer uh but i i think
that
uh the training involved
for both of these spaceships i think is
going to be is going to be primarily
emergency training kind of like
maybe a little more than what you would
normally get on a on an airline flight
you know we all get that emergency
briefing on an airline flight of what to
do if there's a cabin depressurization
you know what what to do if there's a
water landing and so on different things
that you're going to need to know
that you know most passengers worth and
they may not always listen to
i think the people on this space and
these spacecraft will be listening
and it might be a little bit more a
little bit more involved the things they
might need to do to get away from the
spacecraft
so i think that's part of the training i
think the other part of the training is
what they're going to experience
the g-forces that they'll experience the
profile of the
of the mission to give them an idea of
what it's going to be like so it's not
totally unexpected when they
actually do this if you were somebody
who hadn't been to space or now if you
had the money in the time and you wanted
to again how concerned would you be
about
safety i mean astronauts have died is
there any reason to think that these
trips are any more or less safe than
nasa's used to be
well i think these these trips are
certainly safer than what we did with
the space shuttle
i think they're probably and they're
they're also they're not going to orbit
which adds a whole another
phase of complexity and and risk there
there's suborbital flights
so i think as far as space flights go
they're probably as safe as you can get
i do think they are safe there's always
a risk when you
do something like this but i i
don't expect that anything bad is going
to happen i think they're
they're tested spacecraft and they've
done really well
and there's no reason to believe that
they won't have a successful experience
so
there's always that element of danger of
course but i think in this case i i
think that they're gonna
if they're gonna be safe i would be i
would feel safe doing it as as well
um and i i'm not fearful for my uh my
friends that are involved here i think
they're gonna be okay
i mean mike the last shuttle flight was
10 years ago the space race back
50 years ago and now it's private
companies it's virgin galactic and blue
origin whoever else might get into the
game why did our government get out of
the space flight business
anyway our government got out of the
state flight business when did that
happen
don't say that to my friends there's
three americans up there right now
if you think if they hear about that
they're going to be concerned
apologies to the good crew of the iss
but you know what i mean we're not we're
not
doing we're seeding a lot of it to
private corporations
truthfully i don't think that that's 100
percent correct i i think that
nasa is still uh is is still exploring
they have as
people in space right now there are
three americans plus
international astronauts up there as
well a french astronaut there
there's cosmonauts up there with them as
well so uh
and a japanese astronaut too so i think
we have to
we have to say that what's what's actual
going on here and there there's people
still up there i think what you may be
referring to is that
some of the launch services to the
international space station
is still under contract by nasa but it's
private company a little bit of a
different model
private companies have more
responsibility in the building of the
spaceship and also the launching of the
spacecraft
and controlling it until it gets to the
space station and that is a little bit
different nasa was more involved with
the
building of the spacecraft and with the
launching and operating the spacecraft
while it's on its way and during
re-entry
but they still are very much running the
show as far as
who goes on those spacecraft and how
they're used in all the international
space station
and also building a space launch system
which is a bigger rocket
that's going to go to the plan is to
have that go to the moon with the
spacecraft orion
and then on to mars the new model that
they're using is having the contractors
or the these private companies have more
skin in the game
and also that they can use their space
their spaceships
to uh to launch private citizens spacex
for example
uh is going to be participating in the
first private astronaut mission
where three paying customers are going
to be flying to the international space
station
along with one experienced retired
astronaut
the mission commander and that's a bit
different because it but it's still
kind of working with nasa so i think
nasa has kind of turned its attention to
different things
so i wouldn't say they're out of this
space business at all i mean obviously
they're not
they're trying to turn over more of it
to private enterprise so they can do
some of the things that
private enterprise is not ready for yet
but i think we're seeing a significant
step now
in having these private companies take a
larger role
and hopefully they'll be successful and
they'll be economic growth and we'll
have a
thriving commercial space program just
like we have a thriving commercial
airline industry yeah i mean there are
plenty of people in the world now with
money to burn who might want to do this
if they could get a slot i mean space
tourism is away from being a thing most
of us get to do do you see a time when
people could stay in space for a few
days like going to a hotel
for a few thousand dollars say getting a
chance to experience
what either what richard branson and
jeff bezos are going to be experiencing
which is
a suborbital flight or going for a
longer journey
uh i think it's going to be quite
expensive for a while
um but i think both both of those both
richard branson and jeff bezos i think
what they would tell you is that they
understand that
they're going to need for the price to
come down i think the same for the
for going to the space station for for
to really be successful in the long term
the price is going to have to come down
significantly
mars explain why it's just exponentially
more difficult and expensive i mean it's
it's millions of miles it's a years long
thing i mean from
the naked eye you're looking at a
telescope you don't really get a sense
of the sheer distance between the moon
and mars
yeah it's a big difference and it's not
just in the sheer distance in the time
to get there the moon is about a day and
a half trip to get to
mars is about six months and it's only
at certain times of the year that you
can go and the planets are close
so there could be times where you're
very you can't get there at certain
times of the year you have to wait
until the right moments also you have to
wait for the right window of days to
come back
so you're looking at a round trip to
mars of about
two years where you would go for about
six months stay for about a year
and then come back and it's not just
that physical distance
and the time it takes to get there it's
also in the transmission
of of data and signal and communication
between mars and earth and between the
astronauts who will be doing that voyage
so
when we're on the space station or on
this you know we were
on the space shuttle we flew that or on
the space station now
it's a you know it's about a second and
a half or so to get it
you know ask a question you know you say
we have a problem you know you'll get
you'll get
a response fairly quickly but there's
still a bit of a transmission lag
it was about three seconds on the moon
houston we have a problem they got an
answer about three seconds
on mars you're going to say houston we
have a problem and you're going to wait
about 20 or 30 minutes
in angle hill someone say oh what was
that you know so
you know it's it's really not feasible
to operate the way we've operated and
it's interesting speaking to some of the
moonwalkers about how dependent they
were on mission control if you've seen
the
movie apollo 13. they were very
dependent on the control center to get
that help the control center saved the
day
and the way they were able the reason
they're able to do that is because they
weren't that far away
they were able to talk to them
relatively quickly
and get help that's not going to happen
on mars
you're going to be really independent
you're going to be independent to solve
problems
you have to be independent to to fix
if anyone gets sick if there's a problem
with a spaceship whatever it is
you're on your own and that is a much
different equation
certainly from the from being in on the
space station where help isn't really
not that far away
you're going to be so far away on mars
that you're really going to have to be
able to handle everything independently
well mike masamino's good talking to you
former nasa astronaut columbia
university engineering professors he's a
senior advisor for space programs at the
intrepid sea air and space museum in new
york city
uh mike thanks a lot for coming on the
rundown chris really appreciate you
having me
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
this week a 125 year tradition continued
in new york city
since the 1880s ticker tape parades in
lower manhattan have honored kings and
queens
presidents returning soldiers and sports
teams this time
it was essential workers who got the
city through the pandemic that were
honored with the parade
sandra lindsay was the grand marshal and
knows first hand how it was during the
roughest early days of the pandemic in
new york city
she's a critical care nurse who works at
a medical center in queens
and in december she became the first
person in the u.s
to get the covid 19 vaccine after it was
authorized by the fda
sandra had a message for those who are
hesitant to get the shot now
i would say to them look how far we've
come 15 months ago we were in a much
different place
but here we are today celebrating our
hometown heroes
please get vaccinated we cannot go back
to where we were
before look at all the progress we've
made
get vaccinated we can go back to doing
the things we love
some of the many health care workers who
came from across the country to lend a
hand in march and april of last year
made a return trip this week to ride in
the parade other essential workers who
were honored included mta
employees who kept subways and buses
going during the pandemic and they got a
special float of their own
a 118 year old wooden subway car
spectators crowded the canyon of heroes
to cheer
wave and hold signs telling them thank
you
in new york city tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
mark
what's on your mind president biden
missed his july 4th target of getting
first shots into the arms of 70
of american adults if he wants to
convince the vaccine hesitant to get
immunized especially vaccine hesitant
republicans
there's a simple way to do so give
donald trump the credit he deserves for
the vaccines
former presidents george w bush barack
obama bill clinton and jimmy carter were
all invited to record public service ads
urging americans to get vaccinated the
only former president not included was
the one whose voice could have made the
biggest difference
trump this makes no sense today it is
trump supporters who are most likely to
remain unvaccinated
the 20 u.s states with the highest
vaccination rates all voted for biden in
2020.
meanwhile most of the 22 states with the
lowest vaccination rates went to trump
including
almost all the states with vaccination
rates below 50 percent
in conservative mississippi only 38.3
percent of adults are fully vaccinated
compared with 76.1 percent
in liberal vermont if biden wants to
convince those americans to get
immunized
he should remind them that operation
warp speed the greatest public health
achievement in human history
was also the greatest achievement of the
trump presidency trump invested about 10
billion dollars in six vaccine
candidates
purchasing hundreds of millions of doses
of vaccines before they were proven
and clearing away regulatory hurdles all
three vaccines that eventually received
fda approval received critical support
from his administration
before leaving office trump had
contracted to buy at least 800 million
vaccine doses for delivery by july 31st
enough to vaccinate every single
american but instead of giving trump
credit for this accomplishment
biden has tried to downplay trump's law
he falsely declared that quote my
predecessor
as my mother would say god love him
failed to order enough vaccines
unquote indeed biden has tried to take
credit not only for vaccine distribution
but also vaccine development
noting in a recent speech that quote the
science was done under democratic and
republican administrations unquote
this is childish operation war speed
gave us the vaccines
trump led it it was his achievement full
stop
acknowledging this fact does not require
biden to gloss over what he considers
trump's other failures in office or his
behavior after the election
biden is the one who promised to usher
in a new era of bipartisanship
so why can't he admit that his
republican predecessor
delivered the vaccines that are saving
us if biden isn't comfortable touting
trump's achievements himself he could
ask trump to do it
does biden really think that voters in
trump states are going to be persuaded
by appeals from jimmy carter bill
clinton and barack obama to get
immunized
apparently biden considered asking for
trump's help in march he said and i
quote
i discussed it with my team and they say
the thing that has more impact than
anything
trump would say to mega folks is what
the local doctors what the local
preachers with the local people in the
community say
unquote no that's not true indeed
an appeal from trump may very well be
the only thing that would convince some
of his supporters to get their shots
of course trump does not need to wait
for an invitation from biden
he could set up vaccination sites at his
rallies which would give him an
opportunity to tout his administration's
singular success in saving us from
covet-19
and republican governors in pro-trump
states could record public service ads
of their own featuring trump
urging his supporters to get vaccines
that his administration produced
but though those efforts might be useful
it is the sitting president's
responsibility to convince americans to
get immunized
while the biden administration deserves
credit for the effective distribution of
the vaccines it was president trump
who made the vaccines possible the
message to vaccine hesitant republicans
should be
if you trust trump get your trump
vaccine i'm mark thiessen
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast
dive deeper than the headlines in the
party lines as i take on
american life politics and entertainment
subscribe now
on foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes